Shawn O'Hara here on the Rich Eisen show
my colleague from the NFL Media Group
how are you Shawn
I'm doing well where are you calling
from are you or were you arrested are
you in the tank where are you Shawn
what's happening no I'm actually had a
come on a police call American cut I
just said I had a little luncheon that
they call it the ones with the legends
it's New York Times and some of the
sponsors and sweet offers so that means
Eli Manning was there so what do you
mean no I was not Strahan was there was
string in there you I got tackled in the
parking lot he got sacked and Strahan
you know he had to do he had to do
another appearance for his ugly suit
all right so Seaborn was there we see
horn there you know I love it here let's
let's walk I'm gonna walk you all in the
Rich Eisen show if you didn't hear this
story I told last week through ok going
getting ready for the Tuesday night
season to opener edition of NFL gameday
morning ok season preview show and I'm
sitting there thinking I think it's
gonna be Patriots Giants in the
Superbowl I think we're gonna see Eli
and Tom one more time the football gods
want it cuz I like this defense I like
Brandon Marshall in this offense
I think Paul Perkins improved himself
throughout the rest of the year and I
walk into the green room the dressing
room and who do I see sitting in there
sand
not so fast who was that person who was
that person no it was a New York giant
legend who I'm talking to right now
and what did you tell me that was your
doubt go ahead I had some I had some
legitimate concerns about the office of
law yes you did
and did you take that hammer and hit the
nail right on the head man what is going
on with that unit Sean yeah you know
Richard last year we kind of washed it
in we just said well you know
these guys can they get better okay and
everything was they're young you know so
they're going to improve they're gonna
get better and man it just hasn't
happened and I think everybody's
frustrated
the fans are frustrated I think that the
team is frustrated and you know that
Mike my big question Ritchie is just
look if you know you have an offensive
line that's struggling in fast
possession that one-on-one passport is
kind of not their thing why wouldn't you
run the ball more
you brought in a fullback in the
offseason you brought in red Ellison the
Swiss Army knives tight end and yet
they're still acting like they're
allergic to running the ball they have
yet to run the ball three times in a row
at any point this season and Wow you
know you gotta help those guys out so
what's the answer
I mean seriously at one at all in three
going into Tampa which has a pretty damn
good front seven what is the answer
Shawn O'Hara well the one thing that I
think everybody in that locker my
understanding is there is no cavalry
coming there's no key role coming to
save the day
you know the guys got a play better you
know I never I never had a player came
out of loss or came in a week is it hey
coach is gonna draw up some great plays
and all of a sudden they're gonna help
us win the game no it was I guess we
gotta do our jobs better and you know I
think that really that responsibility is
shared across the board you know I could
certainly play better he could mix
better throws the receivers can catch
the ball better
you know the offensive line certainly
can block better at play better but the
situational football's not there you
know look they go for on third and one
and which I gotta be honest if I'm in
the huddle and on third and freakin one
we're gonna call a toss crack and we're
not going to run the ball in the front
side or back side a gap I'm pissed as an
offensive lineman so I saw that play and
I just I got angry I think that this
team's really looking at this and
they're saying look we got it we got to
find a way to create some positive
momentum so I like the way they started
the game last weekend sterling with up
tempo
but no ha no I think that's when he lies
at his best so I think you got to do
something you got to just go with that
and even if you do it for the whole game
at least you wear down the defensible
bit but this is definitely trying times
for for everybody that believes blue
Shawn O'Hara of the NFL Network here on
the Rich Eisen show tonight we see Green
Bay take on the Bears is it safe to say
the Bears have a better offensive line
than Green Bay and that might be a
difference in tonight's game even though
it's heresy to even suggest that Aaron
Rodgers might lose this one in Lambeau
yeah well they're definitely definitely
healthier you know getting Kyle long
back last week helped out you know for
Green Bay
they just keep losing tackle after
tackle and unbelievable I mean Aaron
Rodgers was running for his life that
the fact that they were able to come
back and win that game against
Cincinnati was unbelievable Shawn
yeah what he's been able to do in spite
of what's going on around him just kind
of lets you know what a special talent
he is you know he I think he's he's got
some Jason Bourne like qualities he
seems to always know like where the
escape route is you know he knows that
he could jump out of the third storey
window and he's got a land and a trash
dumpster safely like he's got that knack
I think the offensive line do you you
know I love that you're focusing on on
the big balls because the Bears owe lies
what they say to the Steelers defense
was phenomenal I mean the 220 yards
rushing Mike Glennon didn't have to do
anything all he did do was hand off the
ball so this game was going to be a lot
closer than I think people think and
obviously with the Bears over on their
run game the Green Bay Packers red zone
defense has been very suspect and I'll
say this if Chicago ended up kicking
field goals I think Green Bay wins Aaron
Rodgers gonna find tore Nelson in the
red zone but if the Green Bay Packers
red zone defense don't you find a way to
slow down this run game it's going to be
the Kings coming down to the wire so I'm
paying attention the offensive line
Shawn because I have I have a set of
eyes and I'm seeing what the NFL's
looked like through the first three
weeks of this season
I saw I saw I saw the Cardinals come out
like a house of fire but not able to
close because they couldn't block to
mark DeMarcus Lawrence as a matter of
fact one field goal I mean one touchdown
got got called back because Lawrence are
in a you know drew a holding penalty
despite being part of a three-man rush
I've seen Seattle have major problems
through the first three weeks of this
season and then I've seen other teams
because of their offensive line looked
far more cohesive and have a better shot
at winning football games and I'm
wondering why that is it does it seem to
you that that that that was also see
Garrett bowls on the left tackle and
Denver make a major difference on that
offensive line in the way that teams
look through the first three weeks of
the season what what is the the the
status of line play in the 2017 NFL a
world Sean well it's scary and I tell
you who it's scary for it's scary for
the owners and the teams that are paying
and one guy 25 million dollars and they
can't even protect them in a five yard
pocket so I I think
the crazy thing is received the shift in
pay quarterbacks getting more money
every single year they're getting paid
more and more and more that money's
coming from somewhere well they take it
from the Oh line you know and this is to
me it's like the equivalent of putting a
padlock you know that padlock that you
have on your gym locker on a three
million dollar house you know you don't
go cheap on the security system on a
three million dollar house put up you
know the the state-of-the-art equipment
that's what you're seeing I mean the
Seattle Seahawks have spent the least
amount of money on the office line we
look at all three two teams and it shows
and why they do that cuz they had to pay
Russell but also paint all the guys on
defense so I always said that offensive
linemen are kind of like the tires on
your car nobody paid attention to them
until they go flat so when you take your
Range Rover and rich and they tell you
hey it's gonna cost you a couple grand
because the treads are a little low on
your tires go ahead pay for now don't
wait turn you're on the side of the 405
and you're looking for someone to come
with well Sean are you been away a long
time I don't I don't drive Range Rovers
no more it's Honda Rich Eisen showing
the Honda
all right all right Shawn anyway long
are you sorry you have your own driver
no no no Honda I'm a family man Shawn
okay thanks for thanks for joining a man
you are a legend Shawn you are a legend
you are I'm gonna go I'm gonna go till
3:00 and ya tell stray I said hi and say
Sehorn I said hi okay all right that's I
think I think jockeys in there okay you
take care of that shown around the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our app don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slo-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about